now that we know what a trader means
when they say that a market is in
contango let's think about whether it
would be a bullish or a bearish signal
for prices in that commodity so as I
mentioned in the last video it's
actually normal for things to have a
contango because it takes into account
the opportunity cost of the cash and the
storage cost for that commodity so if
something is kind of in a in a
reasonable contango you really can't
make a call on it one way or the other
words whether it's bullish or bearish
it's really just something that you
would expect what's not as usual is a
severe contango severe contango and
that's when the current spot price is a
lot lower than the futures price or the
forward price and in that situation as
we've mentioned in the last video it's
because that there's there's perceived
to be a big glut in the market there's a
surplus in the spot market or maybe
there's a perceived shortage at some
point in the future and in general this
is perceived although once again you
can't just look at one simple signal and
be able to you know bet your life
savings on the direction of the market
it's a very quick way to lose your money
but the general view is is that a severe
contango is a bearish signal is a bare
signal for the future price of that
commodity and the reason why it's
perceived to be bearish is because if
you have this huge discrepancy all
someone has to do is buy a bunch of oil
today we assume that these were oil
prices so buy a bunch of oil today for
cheap store it and once again we're
assuming this is a severe contango so
this it won't cost us $100 a barrel to
store this this oil for a year and then
we agree to sell it for 150 dollars so
we agree agree to sell it and assuming
the storage cost is less than $100 we're
going to guarantee some money so if you
have a bunch of people doing this buying
on the spot market it will increase
demand on the spot market raise prices
there but for the futures market there's
a bunch of people who are now agreeing
to sell in the future so it's
going to lower it's going to increase
the supply on the selling side of the
futures contract so to lower the futures
prices
so in general severe contango is bearish
for the futures price